-
être resserrer, un reportage.
- Je leur propose ça à tous
les ministres...
- Une carte d'affaires caviardée
pour railler le gouvernement
Legault. Nos révélations sur
les entraves quant à l'accès
à l'information alimentent
les critiques de l'opposition.
JOËL ARSENEAU, député, PQ,
Îles-de-la-Madeleine
- On va utiliser des faux
prétextes, donner de la fausse
information pour bloquer l'accès
à des documents.
- Trois responsables
de l'accès aux documents
expliquent à Radio-Canada
être l'objet de pressions.
Ces sources ont v
leur identité par peur de
représailles. De plus, Radio-
Canada a appris qu'un mécanisme
permet aux établissements de
se concerter avant de répondre
à une demande. Ce qui est
contraire à l'esprit de la loi.
GAÉTAN BARRETTE, porte-parole,
PLQ, accès l'informatiation
- En commençant par assurer,
non pas l'autonomie, mais
l'indépendance de ceux et celles
qui gèrent les demandes d'accès.
GABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS, chef
parlementaire, Québec solidaire
- Ils traitent les
demandent de l'information comme
des menaces. Sauf que la vraie
menace, c'est pas l'information,
c'est pas la transparence.
La vraie menace, là,
c'est la noirceur.
- L'affaire provoque une petite
tempête.
- On est jeudi, mais on a encore
des rè les règles,
il faut les respecter.
- Le gouvernement nie
les allégations d'ingérence
politique.
- C'est pas une intervention
politique, mais ce sont
les présidents, les dirigeants
des CISSS et des CIUSSS qui
s'entendent pas avs de
leurs employés sur ce qu'il faut
donner. Moi, ce que je dis comme
message, aux PDG de CISSS et
CIUSSS, c'est : respectez
la Loi 62 puis tout ce qui peut
être donné doit être donné.
- Mais plusieurs estiment qu'il
faut quand même moderniser
les paramètres.
DIANE POITRAS, présidente,
Commission accès l'information
- Et elle laisse une grande
de discrétion qui ne permet pas
de rendre des décisions
uniquement dans l'intérêt
public.- Le ministre responsabl,
Éric Caire, veut lui simplement
augmenter la quantité de données
qui sont accessibles directement
sur Internet à tous les
citoyens.
Ici Davide Gentile,
Radio-Canada, Mon